[Music]
hi I'm Hannah your friendly neighborhood
wine mom and if you're anything like me
you believe that a glass of wine at
eight pm makes you a better mom so pour
yourself a glass let's talk today we're
drinking a dessert wine it is mango wine
because I just ate basically eight
thousand grams of carbs in the form of
pizza and breadsticks and it's time for
dessert so a couple weeks ago we did a
video about judgy parents and you guys
totally owned it with these amazing
comments sharing stories of all the
times that you were judged and overcame
it when that video was released I was on
a trip with my husband with no service
and I went to this little no arrests up
just to check on the video and I saw all
of the comments and just burst into
tears in front of everyone because it
was so beautiful so thank you so much
and I want to keep it going so let's
talk about something that I see in the
comments a lot it's an issue that we all
have to deal with every day and it's how
I learned to love my mom bod really said
talk about this so first let's talk
about the girls
what are you pregnant your boobs get
huge and they're just like up here like
big perky headlights like Hello Baby on
the way and then as soon as the baby
comes out they just kind of deflate like
sad birthday balloon you know when you
like your kid insists on keeping them in
their room for like a month and a half
and they're just like barely floating
but the way I think about it now is I
kept two humans alive with these
literally these things kept two humans
alive they have accomplished so much you
know what I'm gonna let them retire they
did their job what I gave them a break
for a little bit so this one's for you
I appreciate you next Tiger claws
instead of getting like the typical
tiger claw stretch marks around my belly
I got this weird solo stretch mark right
above my belly button that like
stretched out into a V it's like I'll
show you come come closer don't be shy
it's like kind of weird but I was so
embarrassed by it that for the longest
time after I had my first I would not
even wear a bathing suit like a
two-piece bathing suit I realized that
first of all I'm not going
beach for like some model photoshoot so
who gives a crap if I have the perfect
body suck it I'm not there for anyone
elses viewing pleasure like we're all
there to just go to the beach and three
that mark is the only reminder I have on
my body of the fact that I had both of
my children in there it's mind-boggling
to look at them now and see how huge
they are and look down at my little
stretch mark and remember that this is
where they came from
it's our badge of honor it's beautiful
next the pooch when your stomach has
been stretched out to about here there's
gonna be some extra skin every mom's
stomach is not going to be the same as
it was before they had children that's
just a fact yeah my stomach is a lot
softer and it used to be but let's be
honest I never had a 6-pack to begin
with and as soon as you have the baby
there's all this pressure from the media
and peers and strangers to lose the baby
weight I don't know why that's even a
priority to other people who have not
even had this baby new moms are the most
exhausted people on the planet so for
them to try to focus on like exerting
more energy to try to lose weight is
ridiculous so let's give them a break
new moms don't have to focus on losing
the baby weight just worry about keeping
the child alive and keeping yourself
alive how about that so keep your baby
weight who cares seriously you won't
good Cheers
next the hoo-hah because I'm 5 years old
and I don't like talking about private
still it baffles me that I'm still asked
by so many people do the parts go back
together
the way that they were done back in the
olden olden olden days children did not
survive very well
so women we're supposed to have multiple
kids that means this thing closes right
back up maybe not our tummies but down
there does just fine and I checked with
a mirror as my husband don't ask my
husband that's weird there's a comment
that I get all the time in person and in
the comments of these videos and it's
always you look amazing
for having had two kids and for the
longest time there was this ugly voice
in the back of my head that would say oh
you're only looking good for having two
kids you don't look good for a normal
person something that was meant to be a
compliment would make me feel badly
about myself I felt like my only body
identity was mom I realized I of course
my body identity should be a mom because
I birth to children and that's amazing
and to any of you guys who feel like you
have all this pressure on you to look
perfect or look a certain way or feeling
badly about anything that has happened
to you as a result of having your child
you got to stop what you've done is the
most incredible accomplishment that I
could ever think of like literally
building a human like you made a brain
just the fact that there was a brain in
there that you made that's crazy and
honestly if you're feeling badly turn
off the TV turn off the computer turn
off this crappy media that's making us
feel like we're supposed to look a
certain way or we're supposed to be a
certain way that's completely
unrealistic and unattainable life is way
too short to spend another second hating
your body and I am so freakin passionate
about this I'm about to start crying I'm
not even joking I love my mom bod
I love your mom bod you should love your
mom but so let's celebrate them let's
show them off to the world because [ __ ]
what everyone I shouldn't say the F word
but [ __ ] what anyone else thinks
seriously [ __ ] that we're beautiful and
we should celebrate with lots of wine
and bathing suits so that's all I got
for today I'm Hannah your friendly
neighborhood wine mom and I know I got a
little bit passionate there but this is
just something but I care so much about
I just want to like reach through the
screen and hug you all one of those long
awkward hugs that you're like patting me
on the back being like okay okay so I
want to hear in the comments about why
you love your mom bond and what you love
about your mom bog because they're
beautiful and it's time that we take
over the dad bods because all about the
mom Bob because we're awesome and we
rock and you're all beautiful and
love you so cheery til next time oh
[Music]
sweet barrel why sweetberrywine
[Music]